foreign
call everybody will be talking about
thanks for joining us here at six
o'clock I'm Denise Valdez I'm Brian
Loftus a family says something crashed
into their backyard prompting them to
call 9-1-1 saying they saw creatures
walking around our 8 news now
investigators digging into this for
weeks now and tonight are David charns
with the video you will only see on 8
news now David Brad Denise source is
telling babies now investigators that
several agencies believe something
landed or crashed whether it was
non-humans or not it certainly scared
the people living on this property now
before we show you that video listen to
their call for help
this is like a hateful person beside it
and another one's inside and it has big
eyes and looking at us and it's still
there
okay where is this on your property
uh in my backyard
I swear to God this is not a joke this
is actually weird so there's two people
or two subjects that are in your
backyard
correct and they're very large
they're like gay food
nice
they look like aliens to us
big eyes they have big eyes like like I
can't explain it and think I'm out
they're shiny eyes and
and they're not human they're 100
they're not human
okay
well the 8 news now investigators
obtaining video as officers then
responded to the call you just heard
you'll see the officers also saw
something in the sky that night but the
big question is what was it and is it
all connected
leave her alone it's almost midnight on
May 1st when a Las Vegas metro police
officer's body cam catches this
something flashing low in the sky 911
emergency minutes later there's a
there's like an April person beside it
and another one's inside and it has big
eyes and looking at us and it's still
there someone calls 9-1-1 reporting two
large figures in their backyard oh I'm
so nervous right now the eight news now
investigators obtaining another
officer's video as he sent to the
Northwest Valley home I have butterflies
bro Evelyn's not a shooting star then
these people say there's aliens in their
backyard by now it's more than an hour
after that bright light officers meeting
up with the caller and his family what'd
you see it was like a it was like a big
creature a big creature yeah we're not
going to BS you guys one of my partners
said they saw something fall out of the
sky too so that's why I'm kind of
curious did you see anything land in
your backyard or they see like a big
that's what they say they see like a big
uh like a big something with life what I
saw right now I do believe in it police
walk into the backyard to investigate
but Metro blacked out that part of the
video because it's considered private
property what's clear they're taking
this call seriously hey this might sound
like a really dumb question but did you
guys see anything fall out of the sky
asking others what they saw uh I would
normally discounted as nothing however
um
seen as one of my partners said they saw
it too only reason I'm actually
investigating any further that
investigation turning up no concrete
answers as of Wednesday whatever or
whoever fell into that yard long gone
within minutes oh hey it does it does
nine foot beings come back don't call us
all right deal with it yourself that I
ain't dealing with that
so yeah this is quite Weird Brian was
saying during as we're watching this
story now we've been been in contact
with the family in that video and as you
heard in that 9-1-1 call they seem very
reasonable and honestly quite scared as
you heard them in the call no they don't
seem impaired in any way and whatever
crashed by the time that police got
there was gone but sources say that
there's really no dispute something was
in their yard exactly what
we do not know I mean it's so
interesting so like the Metro officers
see something the neighbors see
something I mean so what could it be
well we know that there are obviously a
lot of military bases around this area
uh George Knapp covers a lot of that
stuff for us on the 80s now
investigators we're showing you drone
video from above that area and we know
of course Creech not far away Nellis Air
Force Base not far I checked in with
them they say they are not involved at
all and we are waiting to hear from the
Pentagon as well and you talk to these
people it seemed completely legitimate
to you and and do you have any personal
thoughts on maybe what it was right so
it seems from talking to our sources
that something happened there was
obviously some flash in the sky a lot of
people saw it that night on the night of
April 30th early in the morning on May
1st did that exact thing land in their
yard I don't know but these people said
they saw some SUVs circling the area
could that could this have been some
piece of equipment that malfunctioned
maybe they saw some something and then
someone came I can't believe we're
talking about this right someone came
and retrieved it from the backyard in
the SUV we don't know this all comes as
a former high-level intelligence officer
an air veteran was on news Nation
talking about how there is a program
where the government collects some
unidentified objects so this might be
that we just don't know we're going to
work to find out though and no
substances they were looking with clear
eyes very interesting not big buggy eyes
though this is really unique thank you
David